Ubisoft has filed the new trademark
application for beyond good and evil
which makes just some movement on the
follow up to the fan favorite game Jill
Jacques discovered in April one listing
in the European Union intellectual
property office database for beyond good
and evil the trademark filed by Ubisoft
that covers video games among other
things this isn't a belated April Fool's
joke though the existence of a trademark
doesn't necessarily mean much on its own
it could just mean Ubisoft is playing it
too safe Andrey securing its rights over
the franchise and their future rights to
branded merchandise like paper products
and clothing a sequel to Beyond Good and
Evil 2 was first announced by director
Michelle and cell in 2008 where he
confirmed that the product had already
been in pre-production for a year and
some alleged gameplay footage leaked
sometime after but we haven't seen
anything else about it since in 2014 a
representative said Ubisoft Montpellier
was still working on the quote extremely
ambitious project but it was quote still
far too early to give many details about
this new title in January of this year
and sell seemed to acknowledge that the
game was still in development on an
episode of Double Fine's devs play
series you'll still be in the headspace
of this game cuz you're making a sequel
right here yeah you want this world yeah
but it it's difficult because I ate out
for me to redo the same kind of game 2
times so I always want to do something
different let me know what you want out
of a sequel and stay tuned to gamespot
we will keep you updated